hey youtubers is Charlie so Season 5
episode 1 is getting ready to air
tonight so I wanted to do a bonus video
for the sons of the harpy one of the
organizations inside Marine there's also
a lot of news going around some some big
stuff happened yesterday so I'll address
that at the end of the video - careful
for spoilers for everything from season
1 to season 4 on the show the sons of
the harpy are a counter insurgent group
put together by the noble houses of
marine before Danny moved in the slaving
houses but they're basically ten big
families that all live in like really
big pyramids they controlled the city
before Daenerys moved in and abolished
slavery
they're pissed they don't like the idea
of democracy which is basically with
Daenerys represents so you have going on
in slavers Bay right now is very much
like like an American Civil War
situation where the states are like hey
we still like slavery we want to keep
doing things the way we've done them
forever Daenerys is like nope not going
to happen
even though she has the unsullied the
second son's her dragons and a lot of
very grateful freedmen it's still not
quite enough to overpower the ruling
families the name the sons of the harpy
derives from the the symbol of the harpy
of the old ghiscari Empire this is where
it gets really interesting because a lot
of historical events in Georgia are
martin's books and in A Song of Ice and
Fire repeat themselves this has all
happened before this will all happen
again it's a very Battlestar type idea
if you look at this image in the trailer
of them pulling the harpy down off the
top of the pyramid it's a metaphor for
the fall of the ghiscari Empire the
Valerians crushed them using their
dragons so Daenerys Valyrian descendent
has come into marine and is tearing down
slavery so you can think of this is like
a mini version of the Valerians war
against the ghiscari to be fair though
the ghiscari weren't like crazy awful
people and they didn't even create the
name slavers Bay although they did
originate all the major cities of
slavers Bay just to refresh your memory
that's a stupor young Chi that's where
the wise masters are the last big group
of people she defeated before she came
to marine and then marine marine is just
the largest city in slavers Bay the
reason it's called slavers Bay the
reason like slavery became such a
problem is because that rose up in the
ashes of the ghiscari Empire like after
the Valerians crush them and made it
impossible for them to grow new crops
people in the area turned to slavery to
survive so you can look at slavery the
sons of the harpy in the prov
the Daenerys has trying to abolish it as
being caused by the Valerians sometimes
the best problems are the ones you
create for yourself and that's true of
all characters on Game of Thrones Jamie
Lannister caused so many problems so
many consequences that he didn't think
about ahead of time Cersei Lannister
same thing so Daenerys has a civil war
in her hands the sons of the harpy
rising up trying to push her out of
murine the person giving them orders in
the books is called the harpy I don't
know if they're going to have that
person on the show or not so far it's a
mystery person but the most likely
candidate in the books is someone that
show has not introduced yet it's not a
character on the show what I think is
going to end up happening on the show is
is that it'll be his door during season
4 he was introduced as the Envoy of the
slaving families so he is like the
representative of the old guard in
Mereen the people that still want a
slave he seems really nice but we'll see
what that goes he's kind of like a Varys
type person he keeps his cards pretty
close to the vest it should go without
saying that the show is going to change
a lot of things from the books but like
as I go along with my episode videos
I'll try to explain what they did and
why they did it
what about solutions though how's the
nearest gonna solve this problem
well she acted like the old Valerians
she would just use her dragons to roast
them alive the problem is is that her
dragons are chained up and drogon is
roaming God's nowhere she also wants to
think of herself as a liberator a
benevolent mother you know Missa that's
what that term means using dragons to
roast her opponents alive is something
that her father would do the Mad King
she doesn't want to be like her dad so
it's gonna be really interesting to see
her try to balance her her true nature
as a Targaryen you know mother of
dragons and her desire to be the mother
of these new people it's like when your
child is first growing up you know a lot
of people say you can't be their best
friend and their parent at the same time
it's only much much later in life that
that can happen right now all these
people in Mereen are like little
children trying to learn a new way so
it's either gonna be the carrot or the
stick or like the stick of fire if you
want to use the dragon analogy when you
think about the whole situation it's
kind of funny because she's really just
trying to fix a very small part of the
Eastern continent it seems like it's
much bigger than it actually is slavery
is a big problem slavers Bay is just
like the central location for slavery in
the Eastern continent it's not like
she's trying to subdue the the entire
eastern continent is
massive just look at the Dothraki see
here then you have like the iron bank
all the money up in Braavos that's a
whole other story but if she can subdue
in unite slavers Bay she will have an
army big enough to take Westeros so she
doesn't need to conquer the entire
eastern continent she just needs to win
popular opinion so I guess when you
think about it though like the sons of
the harpy are really just like co-opting
the name of an empire that fell that
they bear very little resemblance to the
goose Carney weren't even that bad it
was just what things turned into after
the Empire fell we will probably get
like a much better look around the
streets of marine there are actually
statues of harpies all over the place
that's ghiscari architecture there are a
couple places that we will be seeing in
marine that we haven't seen before
including the fighting pits most notably
Daz nags pit that's where they are right
here in this scene as you can see it
looks like the harpies want Daenerys is
head on a pike the fighting pits are
self-explanatory though they're a good
example of an entertainment device used
by the slaving families historically to
keep the citizens happy
it'd be like erecting a giant movie
theater in the middle of like a
low-income housing district it'd be like
yeah we understand you don't have any
money we know things are bad but here
have some entertainment free
entertainment in ancient Rome the
Colosseum ended up being used the exact
same way people could come see crazy
fights and get free food sometimes the
Caesars would give away free bread so
like peasants could come get free bread
and watch people bleed all over the
place Daenerys as you can imagine not a
huge fan of this so so we'll see what's
going to win out Daenerys you know
trying to be this rational new mother
person or like classic Targaryen mother
of dragons one of the things I always
really loved about the show is that even
if you spend a lot of time in the same
cities season two season they always
find new places to film new locations so
the same thing is going to happen in
like all the familiar places like King's
Landing for instance we'll get to see
like a lot of new places inside the city
although I'm most excited to see the
water gardens in Dorne
that's going to blow your mind that in
Braavos you will see those places like
you've never seen before so just a quick
reminder what's going to happen tonight
is after episode 1 airs I'll post my
episode 1 review and that's where I'll
do the giveaway for my signed copies of
feast for crows and dance with Dragons
all you have to do to enter that is be a
subscriber and leave a comment whenever
I post the video real simple and then
I'll announce the winner in my Q&A on
Monday it's going to be the same thing
every week I'll have like a giveaway in
my review video and then Monday I'll
announce the winners in my Q&A videos
and everyone's asking about the leaked
episodes yeah unfortunately like four
episodes from Season 5 leaked I'm not
going to be doing any spoilers I try to
stay away from that kind of stuff I just
asked if you guys want to talk about
that stuff please use spoiler tags in
the comments I know a lot of you guys
have asked for spoiler videos what's
probably going to happen is is after
season 5 will probably be in two winds
of winter territory so we can all start
speculating without worrying about about
spoiling stuff so it'll be a little bit
more fun which reminds me
congratulations to this week's giveaway
winner
Ian Simmons you win an HBO now gift
certificate since it's only available on
iTunes if you live in the UK or
somewhere else will find like a
workaround so don't worry just be sure
to direct message me on the back end of
my channel so I get your contact info so
what's going to happen tonight after the
episode airs is I'll post my episode
review you can click here to watch that
I'll just I'll update the annotation
whenever a post and you can click here
for all my other season 5 videos thank
you so much watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys tonight
you